distant education remains a big
challenge for a lot of parents
yeah but a northwest valley business has
accommodated its employees juggling work
and their child's classes 8 news now
reporter kristen drummond shows us this
arrangement
an adjustment at the all nevada
insurance cindy k agency so i think it's
great that they adapted
to what's going on today okay you good
the las vegas business now allows staff
to bring their children to work
giving six-year-old dolly roop chand a
chance to stay with her mother amrita
during distance education
you get to be in a big open spot
where nobody like bothers you to have
the option
to do that is a great blessing because i
don't know how we would have made it
through the mother of four works full
time she says this arrangement provides
flexibility and certain resources for
her children to succeed
using the workplace internet and space
has been a
dream it's been a great great great help
children are working in different spaces
around the office from the conference
room
to the break room it's been wonderful it
hasn't interfered with work
and it's worked out cindy croit says the
insurance program says her staff stays
on task
she did not want employees choosing
between the job and staying at home
our whole world has just changed so we
need to adjust with those changes
i know it's not your typical work
scenario to bring your kid into work
but felicia de palma remains grateful
her son can come here
he's just right next to me so if he
needs me i have that option to just kind
of pause work
and then go and help him parents finding
success
with an typical situation kristen
drummond 8 news now
a cindy k agency only has a few
employees but it suggests that other
business do try to help their staff if
they can during these
unusual circumstances